good morning John a warning this video
contains realities that are sometimes
unpleasant to confront specifically the
reality of the mortality of humans if
that does not sound like the kind of
thing you want to hear about today
move along there is nothing to see here
if on the other hand nerd singing too
quickly about the inevitability of your
personal demise and indeed Universal
oblivion sounds like your cup of tea
proceed well every living organism at
what time was dust an assemblage of
atoms from our atmosphere and crust
these bits they come together but only
for a time from that very force of
replicator losing from the slime we
exist and then we don't that's just how
we do when everyone you know someday
will also be dead due we're all gonna
die we're all gonna die it's the what's
your thing on which every living thing
can rely we're all gonna die we're all
gonna die everyone so far has died you
there's not a thing that you can do and
you and me and us we're all gonna die
well many folks who hope that there's a
way out of this summit if we think real
hard and act all tough somehow we'll get
along we'll fix those telomeres digitize
our brains freeze our dying body still
the remedies attained well I have some
bad news for you you can't have run the
hearse the explosion of the Sun or heat
death of the universe we're all gonna
die we're all gonna die if the what's
your thing I'm which every living thing
can rely we're all gonna die we're all
gonna die the singularity won't save you
there's nothing that you can do new
meanthat's we're all gonna die I forgot
the last verse um
the marvelous truth of it all is that
death is such a gift because the only
reason we can dies that we even live the
improbability of life and you and me and
us that we existed all the sniffing kiss
and taste and here in Dutch we've used
our minds to make so many awesome things
somehow knowing all of the words in the
song you're listening to right now we're
all gonna die we're all gonna die it's
the one chip thing on which every living
too can rely we're all gonna die we're
all gonna die it's the one thing you
can't live through there's nothing that
you can do and you and me and us we're
all gonna die
so have a good time and be nice to each
other yeah weird song topic though not
that weird if you listen to dear Hank
and John I like to kind of understand my
place in the universe and understanding
that it is a brief place it's not really
how places work but you get what I mean
is important to me and now I find myself
with some extra time so what's going on
in my life making a lot of thigh shows
making some crash courses just started
shooting our new crash course series
crash course philosophy which won't be
uploaded for quite a while yet so I
apologize for teasing I haven't seen
Star Wars yet I don't know what kind of
nerd I think I am and we just recorded
our 29th podcast I cannot believe that
we have been dear Hank and John for 29
weeks and it was a real good one it'll
be out on Monday or Tuesday we're not
great with the schedule is that an idea
uh so I just gave you some bad news the
good news though there's lots of it
scheduled flights between the u.s. and
Cuba are going to resume for the first
time in 50 years the world just had its
first year in which the global economy
grew while global carbon emissions did
not and uh women just voted for the
first time in Saudi Arabia and also some
of them were voted into elected
positions I know it seems like maybe
that shouldn't have just happened now
but at least it happened so yes bad news
some good news it although this is out
everything's gonna be fine right you're
good I hope John I'll see you on Tuesday